the prime minister risks losing the next
election unless he makes more progress
on levelling up that is the warning from
the conservative mayor of teas valley
ben houchin he says the government will
be punished unless new jobs and
infrastructure is delivered to the
regions by the leaders in his own party
well uh ben houchen joins me now to
discuss more on his stark warning to the
prime minister and this conservative
government mr howard good to see you
this afternoon
thanks for having me and just looking um
at your area in context t side 2017 five
labour mps one tory 2019 general
election three labour three tory those
former um labour safe seats turning blue
and that was done many would see on the
promises boris johnson made and linked
to levelling up in the north since the
general election the last general
election
have the people of t side seen any of
these promises materialize
well actually i think in t side we're
one of the few areas that can point to
tangible progress towards leveling up
whether that's the the free port that we
we've got now um on the river tees the
treasury moving to darlington uh
upgrades of local railway stations there
is there is a lot to start leveling up
and that's not to mean that it's done
there's still a long way to go many
years worth of improvements but my
argument today is that we need to
replicate what's happening in t side
across large parts of the north of
england because
you know in 2019 the government was
elected on the promise of leveling up
boris johnson was given the support of
local people uh not just in t-side but
across the north because of what he did
with brexit he delivered brexit and
people associated with him with him
with somebody who was going to deliver
on his promises but obviously with covid
and rightly that did get in the way and
that took up a lot of government time
but now we look touchwood to be coming
towards the end of kovid the government
needs to get back on its agenda of
delivering levelling up because i think
that's the thing that will really swing
people's vote of the next general
election yeah covet has been seen as a
distraction from the leveling up agenda
we're still going through a pandemic but
as you said eyes are now turning to
those uh those promises and talk to me
about what leveling up means then for
the wider area you're talking about
outside of t side because at the moment
there is a cost of living crisis for
example would it mean more to people in
the north to have help to pay
their heating bills than it would be to
say get a new train station
well i think leveling up actually helps
deliver on some of those uh issues that
we're facing today so actually leveling
up on for me my personal opinion on
phase one is around large infrastructure
because it's infrastructure that large
parts of the north of england haven't
had for decades and the governments of
both colours that's better roads it's
better rail it's more bus services it's
even infrastructure that will help
enable private sector investment and if
you look for specifically at the cost of
living in particular around energy
pricing there's more that could be done
by the government and people like off
gen to be able to approve more energy
production more gas production within
the uk that it currently isn't and
actually a lot of that would take place
in places like the north of england
creating many thousands of jobs for
people in good well-paid sectors so all
of this comes together phase one is
about getting large parts of the north
of england to the starting line because
there are places including like t-side
that don't have a metro system we don't
have a regular bus system we don't have
the fantastic infrastructure that other
cities and parts of the south have and
then it allows us to give back to uk plc
and that will by definition address some
of those cost of living issues that
you've just raised yeah people's pockets
being squeezed but the government would
argue that their pockets are squeezed as
well do you think that the government
can level up and cut taxes
and this is a really interesting
argument about levelling up because
people assume if you're in favor of
leveling up you're therefore in favor of
just spending huge sums of money
irrespective of from what may and
actually it's a bit of a balance there
is going to be investment needed from
the government when it talks about
public infrastructure those things that
i've just talked about around rail and
road and buses etc making sure that
people can connect to those
opportunities for jobs and investment
but actually enabling infrastructure
will give more confidence to the private
sector and international corporates and
money from across the world to come and
invest in the uk that's private money
coming in that's leveraging the money
that the government uh can put in it
creates jobs that means more tax take it
means that we're getting more businesses
setting up in the uk so leveling up is
not mutually exclusive from being able
to try and keep taxes low and
incentivize the private sector those two
things go hand in hand and t-side's a
great example of that right we we are
the architect of one of the most free
market policies that this government has
come up with in free parts that doesn't
require hard cash it requires a
framework that enables the private
sector which they're already doing to
come and invest money and create jobs
cct side very much as a blueprint for
perhaps those areas of the north that
aren't benefiting from the leveling up
agenda yet there's quite a gap isn't
there between now and the 2019 general
election if you look at what labour is
saying they're sort of looking towards a
general election in the summer of next
year that's not a lot of time for boris
johnson to prove to northern voters that
he's serious about leveling up what can
he do between now and then to convince
them that he that they should still give
him their vote and not turn back to
labour because sakia starman last week
in his new year speech pretty much said
you know if you voted conservative last
time look again look again at labour
well you know we've talked about covert
and the fact that that's put a delay on
the government plans for levelling up
but what we actually need is people need
to see physical and tangible progress
towards it by the time of the next
general election and people are you know
people are reasonable people are mature
and grown up they recognize that the gap
between the north and the south of
england is not going to be bridged by
the time of the next general election
whether that's next year or in 2024 what
is physical and tangible that can be
done between now and the summer of 2023
well a huge amount and i could argue
that you could argue whether the
election's going to be in 2023 but it's
still a year to be able to get spades in
the ground people need to see things
starting they need to see that their
infrastructure is getting better it
doesn't need to be better they just need
to see that those physical improvements
are real and tangible they're not just
announcements they're not just headlines
that people can see when they go out
their front door things are changing
there are more jobs in their local area
they can feel that their area is
improving and moving towards progress it
doesn't necessarily mean that it has to
be achieved and that that allows the
government to get good will with the
public it allows them to build up some
good will to then buy into what is a
very long-term project in leveling up
okay it's a question of goodwill which
is a question of priorities from the
government those priorities set by the
leader it's a question of leadership
there's a sky news poll of the
conservative membership that said the 34
of members say boris johnson should
stand down that's compared to 9
in july
2020 where do you stand on that do you
think he is the right man to lead the
conservatives
i mean i could be wrong i've been busy
but i think i saw some of the polls out
this morning i think the majority of
conservative members still think that
he's the right man for the job and i
must be honest i am absolutely one of
those people he uh boris personally
connects with people in a way that most
politicians can't and if people can see
progress towards like i say the leveling
up agenda that you set out then people
will vote for boris again you know
people want to be proven right they want
to know
but when they voted for the first time
ever for the conservatives that they did
the right thing by changing what was a
lifetime habit so people want to do it
but we need to give them the excuse and
that means spades in the ground tangible
differences and i do think that boris is
the right man for the job and you trust
him to deliver on those promises even
though he hasn't done yet for large
parts of the north because again i refer
back to the sky news poll 39 of the
membership don't trust him with the
truth do you trust him with the truth do
you trust him to deliver on his promises
well i do think he will and i think
having been a mayor himself he
understands the need to be able to
deliver tangible things on the ground i
think it's absolutely fair to say that
the last two years and rightly so have
been completely consumed by the pandemic
and getting through covert and like you
say we're not quite there yet but it
feels to me like we're coming towards
the end and now my call today is look
prime minister you've got two years
it's gonna be it's not the four years
that you would have wanted to come
concentrate on leveling up but you now
need to deliver on that you need to
start showing that progress and i think
he will do it but today is a call to get
him to refocus because you know i've
just been listening to your program
today and there's lots of other noise
there's lots of other things going on
but leveling up was the thing that got
him elected it was the reason that
people voted for him for the first time
uh in large parts of the north of
england and he and he can't forget that
he's got to deliver on it okay ben houch
and meredith tease i'd really good to
talk to you this afternoon here on sky
news thank you